this video is sponsored by book Walker I
want you to cast your mind back to 2013
this current generation console will had
just begun Harlem shake was a thing and
you to rewind was um full of youtubers
now if you were to head towards the
anime community however what you would
have found it this was the year attack
when Tyson took over and I don't just
mean for the anime fandom it blasted the
shackles of the community to find a
wider vast mainstream appeal which had
never been done before for a single
season excuse me for a second for a
single season of anime conventions were
flooded with people in a survey called
uniform memes were absolutely
inescapable on the internet and
somewhere in between all that attack on
Titan also aired I knew something was
[ __ ] weird when my co-workers in my
office job at the time started off
handedly mentioning attack on Titan in
the same conversation as Game of Thrones
mostly because people are saying it's
basically like Game of Thrones for
anyone who's gotten into anime more
recently is kind of hard to convey how
unprecedented a phenomenon this show was
there'd never been such a meteoric rise
in the history of the medium and the
only thing has come close is the one
punchy boy and I mean nowadays has
become a much more accepted medium and I
honestly think attack on Titan was what
set the ball rolling for that the
franchise had the entire community in
the palm of his hand and all I had to do
to continue that hype train was anything
and then it didn't but after four years
it returns with season two and has been
going strong since then with attack on
Titan season 3 part 2 episode 12 chapter
3 Arsenio having just finished I'm not
gonna pretend that the series isn't
still immensely popular but the hype is
certainly just a fraction of what it was
which is a shame because with this
latest season the series has evolved and
changed so much that as someone who is
initially very lukewarm about the series
I think where it is right now it's
shaping up to be one of the greatest
anime of the modern age and I don't use
those words lightly what I'm trying to
say is attack on Titan is pretty great
and has turned into something pretty
great and as the series goes on it gets
even more great so I just wanted to make
a video about how great it was that I
mention it was pretty great originally
this was just gonna be a short video
talking about how good the new season is
then the more I worked in it the more I
realized I really couldn't do it justice
without talking about the entire journey
we took to get here because every season
is so vastly different from each other
and yet builds on and adds to the
overall experience there will be
spoilers in this video but I won't be
spoiling anything from the later season
because it's my long-winded way of
saying you should drop everything
because this latest season is absolutely
worth it
so buckle up your seat belts put your
phone on silent take a break from your
Joe Joe memes because it's gonna be a
long one because it's one of the few
people who waited all these years
without buckling in tree the manga
experiencing all this for the first time
now all I can say is if I can give
season one credit for anything that it
immediately grabbed your attention then
[ __ ] bear hug day until you can look
in any other direction I think many
people can agree that the first few
episodes is one of the best hooks you
can find an anime in contrast to the
rest of the season where you'll find a
whole mixed bag of opinions ranging from
this is the greatest series ever - this
is an overrated piece of crap - I want
Levi to step on me says eren jaeger I
personally thought it was a ke but
lacking in a few places and I know
everyone's given their two cents on this
by now so I'll try to avoid repeating
any common things
yes everyone got bored of seeing it
everywhere we all know you're not a real
critic unless you complain about the
pair
[Music]
sing the series and I really don't care
if you're a special flower who thinks
the second opening is better than the
first so there's not so before I get
into what I thought the series was
lacking compared to what we have now I
wanted to shine a spotlight and what I
fought it was doing right the entire
time and war he continues to do to this
day
aside from the obvious effects caught of
the amazing action is the armor was
Abel's craft is really believable world
with what felt like a unique premise
I've always loved the world building an
attack on Titan because it never needed
huge exposition dumps of dialogue and
law to lend to his credibility that it
existed because it just felt like it did
it's the attention to detail that gave
the world so much life and made it so
interesting and I know I'm speaking very
broadly here so let me give you a
counter example let's throw all this out
of the window for a second and talk
about Naruto Naruto has a world with a
rich law that intertwines all the
different clans and bloodlines creating
a belief will history you that you can
totally immerse yourself into but
there's one thing that's always bothered
Lee about it what the [ __ ] is the
technology in this world these ninjas
have cameras computers satellite dishes
bloody television sets and they are just
randomly there and they're not there
throughout the series these are all very
small superficial things that shouldn't
affect your overall enjoyment of the
franchise but if you really think about
it it really [ __ ] some of the world's
logic and raises way more questions than
it should like you have magic ninjas
controlling mystical beast second level
entire cities with a single farts cool I
can believe that no problem by having a
whole room of meditates and ninjas
singing Kumbaya for chakra communication
when wireless transmitters have clearly
been used before what radio waves and
satellite dishes obviously exist so why
is important inventions like radar not a
thing on the battlefield or why is
technology not more widely used in
warfare in general and here you got a
car ski using some high-level
communication dude c4 is basically a
Google Hangouts Christ guys stop being
so try-hard and just start a [ __ ]
discord server I'm not saying I want to
see ninjas running around with [ __ ]
air pods but if you're gonna add some of
these elements in your fictional world
for some kind of aesthetic reason while
it doesn't matter in the grand scheme of
things and I'm sure some theory can
explain it it just doesn't feel organic
now this all may sound like nitpicking
to you cuz it totally is but the point
I'm trying to get at is
that in the world of attack on Titan
everything just makes sense from the
social political structure to the
protocols for certain situations to the
wall having a religion to the
sophisticated mechanics of how the ODN
gear works every aspect of this world
seems to have been intricately crafted
from the ground up the wave functions
and develops seems like a logical
product of the initial rules that accept
and as the series goes on and more
aspects get explored you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah of course that's how things work I
don't think about that till now you can
tell a lot of thoughts has been puts
into even the tiniest details even if
they don't explain everything like I
don't need a five-minute explanation on
how they have an invention to get horses
up and over the walls but it's there in
the background and it's not exactly
something you'd immediately think about
but yeah of course they'd obviously need
one sometimes it's the smallest details
I can lend the credibility of your world
and one thing that made Titan such a
convincing threat was that they set up
its rules then a dear to them under real
world logic if you don't have anywhere
to grapple on to you are [ __ ]
if you run out of gas you are [ __ ] if
you sustained an injury from some random
debris shot a landing or an apron a
[ __ ] horse fastball that's you you
are [ __ ] because of course you are
this isn't the usual animate logic where
you have high school kids being flung
through five walls of pure concrete and
then no one's even remotely surprised
when they dig through four tons of
rubble with only a single scratch being
like which is something everybody likes
and has stayed consistent throughout the
series but to get back to why I never
held the series in the highest regards
the biggest problem about it was that
after everything was said and done it
all felt very superficial what I mean by
that is a lot of the appeal came from
shallower elements that were there to
maximize impact but not really leave a
lasting impression from the bombastic
action through the rapids out there to
sound those tracks blaring in your face
out Paul
there was always some kind of twist and
turn to keep you watching even if it
relied on cheap shock factor but I can't
force feeding you something every
episode so you never get a chance to
rest and reflect on it cheap thrills
took priority over actually taking time
to develop these characters with the
possible exception of Jean John whatever
meaning most of them were just
recognizable for a single quirk or were
one no characters introduced for the
purpose of being killed off the
developments contributed to constant
shocking and hype moments but once the
initial adrenaline wears off you've
realized there was not much else there
like he's actually a Titan it was a
prank
it's just prank bro be sure to LIKE
subscribe for more content when I equate
season 1 to is a rollercoaster ride and
I'm not talking about those donkey
pop-up coasters you find out your local
kind of war whatever I'm talking nemesis
Inferno at Thorpe Park King the car at
Six Flags the [ __ ] attack on Titan
riding Fuji who Japan wait a minute it
was a high budget premium thrill ride
but it was a thrill ride nonetheless
because of this when the show ended I
undoubtedly had a great time watching it
but looking back I had zero emotional
attachment to it and that's how it was
for a long long long ass time and then
if the reception for season one was
unbridled hype and excitement when
season two aired it was much more like
hey guys attack on Titan season 2 it's
coming out alright we can fix this can
you get me the high button please a lot
of this can be attributed to the four
year gap but I think another big reason
was that it was just vastly different in
tone and pacing causing a lot of people
to feel a bit underwhelmed by it in
comparison despite this however it may
come to a shock to many of you that I
actually prefer to attack on Titan
season two over season why oh you know
it would be shocking if I didn't already
make a video literally called why I
actually preferred attack on Titan
season two over season 1 season 2 made
me infinitely more invested in the
franchise than I had ever been before
and the way it was able to make me do
this was by stopping the rollercoaster
letting you get off the ride and just
explore the theme park at a slower pace
I swear this is what a theme park
analogy ends I just really want to go to
Thor park and added a lot of these
mystery elements which really enriched
my interest in the world and added a
layer of tension to it JJ Abrams has
this great little TED talk where he
explains his theory behind the mystery
box where when watching a show or movie
you can always find these mystery boxes
where information is fed to you but just
enough is withheld to create a mystery
and it's the withholding of the
information that is far more engaging
for the viewer because we invest
ourselves to find out what's in a box
and that's exactly what happens here it
constantly gave you these little tidbits
and flashback of conversations that
imply that there was something much
larger going on in the grand scheme of
things we're not giving you enough
information for any of it to make sense
and I got you curious and invested to
see what was in this mystery box which
in the series was literally what's in a
bluesman there was real tension in the
air because you didn't know what was
going on who was a Titan who was in a
net who wasn't what did this flashback
mean why is there talking gorilla I
can't be a talking gorilla because I'm
already Winston and the more you found
out the more questions that were raised
there was a lot more emotions evoke than
just shock and awe and improved me that
the series could do more than one thing
also gave a good amount of screen time
on characters who hardly got any before
so much so that the main trio were
barely there in the first half and one
of the most popular characters Levi was
almost non-existent
Levi more likely by amirite
[Laughter]
seasons he managed to make you invest
and care about these characters who you
didn't even remember existed in season
one like I remember back when the first
season was in the prime of his hype i
actually got spoiled about the reveal of
who the colossal and armored Titan was
and my actual response back then was our
for [ __ ] sake I can't believe the
interest done this again this has ruined
the entire [ __ ] thing for me god damn
it I'm [ __ ] pissed
wait who but holds Reiner you me and
crystal all took the spotlight for a
good portion of the season and I ended
up really liking all of them which is
incredible because going to this all I
remember about them was I'm pretty sure
you had two lines before you were a
background character I think cheap waifu
baits I don't even think you're in
season one it's in taking time to
establish these characters and building
up the mystery of the world I felt they
were setting up a story with an actual
foundation rather than setting up the
next big shocking moment and that's
honestly why I preferred the season that
felt less like a string of moments and
more like a narrative that followed a
set of characters with their own drives
and motivations with moments that
organically resulted from it because
there was still some great moments even
if they came there lower quantity now
while I can understand that as a
standalone season not everyone will
agree that this slow methodical build-up
was more entertaining than the
action-packed thrill rides I don't think
anyone can argue about the results that
this foundation paved the way for murder
season two was where we had some
breathing room to really get to know the
characters more season three straight-up
explored aspects of them we've never
seen before by putting them in really
interesting scenarios because out of
nowhere the series turns into this
political thriller where it's all about
scheming conspiracies vying for power
and more importantly some good old human
on human killing action gun was a simple
premise of the heroic humans versus the
monstrous Titans and while a big reason
for the show's popularity and appeal was
the fact that this was a conflict so
simple anyone could get behind it
it was refreshing to see these
characters be put in a morally gray
situation Levi and the whole hanji squad
went from these simple badass characters
who were really good at fighting Titans
to decisive cutthroat soldiers who
didn't hesitate to get the hands dirty
in order to get the job done and we get
to see the young trainees we grew up
with having to make that same difficult
decision of joining them in killing
fellow humans or dying and I just enjoy
seeing them be putting moral dilemmas
where they like what the [ __ ] why are we
fighting humans because humans are
trying to kill us now on Titan we can
call an attack on Mikasa sweet ass with
sugar on top people go you just shut the
[ __ ] up and kill that bloke over there
I'm paraphrasing here there wasn't any
new revolutionary writing technique on
display here all Lisa Yama did was put
his characters in interesting scenarios
to see how they would react and it
worked it really added a layer of
complexity when the enemy wasn't just
some mindless giant zombie but a human
being
acting with their own reasons meaning
the resulting consequences of everyone's
actions had far more weight than ever
used to once again we get a swap on the
character getting the majority of the
focuses Levi went from having a minute
of screen time to being in every episode
Levi more likely hi that's the last time
I swear to God and it's really cemented
the strengths showcase last season that
the series really isn't dependent on any
one character to carry this show because
they all can it doesn't matter if some
characters had like 10 minutes of screen
time before the series is able to bring
any character to the forefront and make
them interesting or so the other thing
is allowed the season to do was to have
outstanding moments that didn't need to
rely on action in fact the best scenes
purely revolved around character
decisions like the phenomenal scene with
historia aka the wife who formerly known
as Krista so the scene basically
revolves around is whether she should
accept her
heritage or reject it now I'm not really
an animated guy when watching anime
there could be this really hype scene
and in my head I'm like oh but on the
outside I'm like so I surprised even
myself when the wife who formerly known
as Chris sir smacks a vial out of the
hand
I've visibly lapped out my seat and
shouted yes go go god I [ __ ] love
this moment so much
and what I loved about it was that like
the rest of the season Issa yama
presented a difficult character choice
and you genuinely did not know what they
would choose especially because what she
chose to do was the harder choice by
doing this not only does she have to
reject her father and a more cushy life
but also her right to attain the power
of essentially a Titan God meaning
humanity will now have to go down an
unknown but far more challenging path so
it gives us so much more weight when she
chooses not only to reject all that but
[ __ ] do it by judo flipping her dick
father breaking his back smacking Aaron
in a head and telling him to stop being
such a bloody cry-baby Landing the
killing blow so the public will have
faith in her as a new queen and then
just for good measure having the balls
to punch Levi all in a good day's work
pure and simple this is just great
writing and that was the point when I
realized holy crap this series might
actually be something really special
hopefully you're getting the idea by now
that every arc so far has taken what's
been previously established and added
something new and built upon that
foundation but that doesn't really
happen in the next arc because it kind
of just does everything at one
remember one attack on Titan was about
Titans remember when it was about
humanity taking back the walls remember
when it was about getting to Aaron's
basement League are you happy now he
happy are you finally gonna shut the
[ __ ] up
attack on Titan season 3 part 2 god that
name never rolls off the tongue no
matter how many times I say it is a
combination of everything the series has
built up its the action-packed
rollercoaster of the first season with
the weight of the second the emotional
complexity of the third and holy [ __ ] is
it an amazing sight to behold you may
not like it but this is what peak attack
on Titan looks like it's like the series
is going through a greatest hits
compilation of everything you was able
to achieve where the final product is
even better than all the individual
elements it added
you've still got the amazingly directed
action sequences the epic reveal of the
world and the mysteries built up really
difficult character decisions
consequence to every action and all this
equates to an experience you can rarely
find in anime
I really hate how cliched the term GBC
has become because this is truly
edge-of-your-seat stuff but I don't feel
that terminus justice to convey just how
well it's built up its characters and
stakes so you go to every episode with a
mix of fear excitement and anticipation
because you genuinely do not know what
is going to happen you watch with bated
breath knowing not everyone is going to
make it out of this it's not a matter of
if it's a matter of who when and how
many and now that we've reached a point
where you actually care about these
characters and it's not [ __ ] to line
lenny right into his death every vent
whether that be a small victory in
battle or someone's unfortunate demise
has tremendous weight behind it side
characters no longer feel like side
characters most of them now you've
gotten to know for a decent amount of
time with meaningful development and I'm
not talking about something like arc one
Aaron gets kidnapped arc two Aaron gets
kidnapped arc three Aaron gets kidnapped
arc 4 Aaron doesn't get kidnapped that's
some premium character development right
there you're invested you're hopeful
you've gone through this long arduous
journey with them and seeing everyone
playing this giant game of Russian
roulette every episode brings the same
kind of squeaky bum gut-wrenching
tension as when it's the 90th minute in
the World Cup final it's stoppage time
and your team is one goal away from
winning or losing the entire tournament
except this isn't some live sporting
event
it's a premade animation it brings an
emotional weight that has never been
reached before by the show and is rarely
reached by any show and none of this
would have been possible without the way
it's constantly evolved and built up
upon itself essentially the series
itself went on this 26 episode
hyperbolic time chamber training art put
the plot and hold level up every aspect
to continuous journey stronger than ever
so now I hope you understand why I've
needed to spend 19 minutes of your time
going through every season explaining
what all the individual seasons have
done and that's because where we are at
right now would not be possible without
the combined effort of every season and
now that we're at this point looking
back at season 1 there were a lot of
elements I wasn't too fond of back then
that now I'm glad they did I'm glad
people can change into Titan so I'm glad
they didn't just take the ball back
straight away I'm glad they took the
time to introduce a female Titan and
this mysterious external and
who wants to destroy humanity I'm glad I
didn't just stay on that simple roller
coaster and stick to humans versus
mindless Titans because now the story is
far more intricate and diverse than
anything I had predicted when I first
started watching it after this latest
reveal the vaults in the basement and
the secrets of the world have been
unpacked
once again the show has evolved into
something entirely new it doesn't even
feel like the same show anymore and I
mean that in a good way it's resulted in
a far more interesting world with a
richer history than I ever thought it
was going to be while still sticking to
the same themes presented in Episode one
and three me realizing this I've just
come to appreciate how rare and enigma
of this show has become because it's one
that has been fully able to realize his
potential till the very end how many of
you have had an anime you like so you go
off to read the source material only to
find that the anime barely scratched the
surface and the source material reaches
Heights you can only dream of seeing in
the anime
well attack on Titan is that one in a
million adaptation not just a really
good short hard-hitting series that said
its peace and ended but a full epic that
we've gone on this long ride with and
has been able to hit its final form with
no compromise in the process of making
this video season 4 was announced which
is going to be the final season we are
going to see a conclusion to this story
and if word of mouth of every margarita
I've talked to is true things are going
to get even better which considering how
things have been set up now
I absolutely believe so here I am now in
2019 and ironically telling you that you
should watch attack on Titan whether
you're a new fan and always won or even
someone who wasn't too hot on season 1
because when I say I like attack on
Titan a lot of people still associate it
with that one dimensional rollercoaster
season one was and it's just so much
more than that now believe the hype
believe the anticipation but get what I
said about the death of classic anime
because when this ends if by some
miracle it is able to continue to get
the same amazing treatment this
adaptation has received thus far this
could very much be the anime that
defines this
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you to book Walker for sponsoring
me to just be able to talk about to
tackle untighten for 20 plus minutes I
really enjoyed making this video call me
in at a concise and fanboy because I
just freaking love it now all the
available attack on Titan volumes are
available on their website in eBook form
in fact you can pick up right where I
left off where the anime ended by
clicking on the link in the description
which will take you straight to volume
23 onwards if you can't wait till season
forward to come out again if you're a
first-time user use coupon code Giga for
five dollars off anyway that's it from
me though I hope you all have a
wonderful day
get on the attack on Titan hype train
and I'll see you all next time